hey guys I'm Kiran Shipka and I'm
Isabella Medicine and we are doing the
wire to auto-complete interview oh
[Music]
you're like Ryan Reynolds right now see
it's the board is Kiernan Shipka nice I
don't know that's that's not a question
that I feel like I see we cast the
spells on people know you're really nice
you everything I would like to thank
good everyone like you would take a
stranger on the streets definitely it
scared of ship good vegan ooh um no I'm
not vegan
I ate eggs and dairy I think cheese is
probably my favorite food I'm like it's
a shame and a papallacta I know there's
a sad I love ice cream so much yeah I do
like making things are like coconut milk
nut milk alternatives all that kind of
stuff super delicious yeah yeah milk
love a skirt and Shipka beauty no it's
definitely not I would not say I'm I'm
Beauty personified at all is Cara Shipka
Irish indeed I am
62% Irish hence the name Kiernan my
middle name is Brennan which is also
very Irish have a lot of Irish people in
my family my mom's name's Erin also very
Irish is Kiernan Shipka related to
Melissa Joan Hart no I'm not I've
actually never met Alyssa Joan Hart even
though we do both play Sabrina she's
she's the previous Sabrina I am the
current Sabrina never met and not
related but I would love to meet her one
day it'd be awesome she tweeted me once
that's fun Wow
yeah how is Kiernan Shipka pronounced
Kiernan Shipka
Kiernan Shipka Garin Shipka oh my god so
cool can we go my nails Isabelle I get
that all the time really people who
should have shown me pictures of hurt
and asked me to sign them and I'm like
that's not me but I signed them anyways
is Isabela Merced married I do have a
ring on that finger
but someone here today wow I guess I got
married today to myself to each other
here I propose to I'm a ghost of her
earlier today was really cute gonna tell
anyone but is this a polymer said Dora
si soy Dora Isabela Merced adopted no I
can see why you thought that because of
instant family but um no is Isabela
Merced related to Vanessa oh gee I wish
I wish I wish she followed me the other
day yes your house - from - oh yeah we
all made it yeah Gabriela I was
following you on Instagram yeah it's big
you can sing though you could say
Michael I just found out before this
lets a collab okay let's do it is a
bomber scented curatorship good collab
yeah it's happening guys yes
Oh with more who does Kiernan Shipka
look like I would say I look like my mom
and I look like Emma Watson I get Emma
Watson Oman I see that get it a lot when
you were saying you get photos of Becky
G to sign I get a lot of Emma Watson
photos to sign this Karen and Shipka
have a sister I do not have a dog um but
I do not have a sister does Kiernan
Shipka have a snapchat and i don't have
a public snapchat i used to have a
private snapchat back in the day when I
felt like all my friends were
snapchatting I just killed my battery I
was tired of it yeah did Kiernan Shipka
go to college no I'm 19 years old I've
taken a lot of college courses but I got
Sabrina right when I was about to kind
of consider going to college did Kiernan
Shipka did I sing I have sung in the
past I will probably sing in the future
I'm singing right now so yes and all the
tenses
yes Isabel ever said tattoo I did get a
tattoo if that's what if that's what
this person is asking it's really small
but I want to get more nice which I do I
do I'm already thinking I just I'm
indecisive or that could mean like
Isabella Morse at tattoo like a tattoo
of your face of other people oh yeah
don't do that it must be a thing
Isabella Marzette see I told you these
nails would be an issue they're cute
though okay Isabella Merced zodiac I'm a
cancer nice what about you Scorpio
there's Scorpio Pisces Oh oh yeah baby
my mom's a cancer though we're really
cancers and Scorpios are very compatible
if the Bella Merced is I injury by
injury
oh that's right I was in this yoga class
and the instructor was really hot and he
said do a headstand and I said I will
for you and so I did one but it was
right after a long flight yeah so
something weird about the blood vessels
and whatnot and it popped
high blood vessel popped and he was
always felt like for being born that way
yeah definitely always though anyways
Isabella Merced makeup that's it
Allen face follow him on Instagram he's
a nice talent he's a big talent Bella
Merced middle name it's Yolanda techne
my my grandma's my grandma's first name
and that's why I changed my last name
that's her middle name
Isabella Merced dog Pluto well since you
asked he is the angel he's like the best
thing in my life and I didn't think you
could have a connection with a dog I
really he's a legend I didn't think you
couldn't and I met him and yeah he
really is great so all right
Kiernan Shipka skincare I swear by some
retinol i love retinol I think that's
very good for your skin and face oil I
love it for a long time I thought I'm
not gonna put oil on my face that's
gonna make it oily or kind of not true
kind of love face oil
SPF water
sleep not that you asked just as Karen
Shepard skincare it's awesome what does
she do or okay he did here took the face
shape never thought of that in my life
before to be quite honest round question
mark
I'd say it's it is face its face face uh
Kiernan Shipka family guy not I I have
no idea I mean I've never I don't think
I've ever been on Family Guy I don't
know
kinship ballet used to good point for a
while my feet are kind of messed up
because of it but that lays beautiful
you did point oh yeah my toenails will
just fall off every once in a while
drama the way
Kiernan Shipka natural blonde no not at
all look at my eyebrows already natural
color of my hair
definitely natural blonde and I wear a
wig on Sabrina so that's not natural
Thank You Man what what is Isabella
Merced Instagram
Isabella Merced that is my Instagram you
can what nationality is Isabella my said
last one in the States yep but I'm half
Peruvian if that's what you're wondering
what is Isabella Merced age I'm 18
July 10 cancer as you know what is
Isabella Merced snapchats it's a very
common one nothing who's trying to
snapchat me yeah have you ever like
opened and message from a from a random
stranger like no instagrams my DM so
yeah for sure in dm's yeah definitely
there's a person that message me for 365
days straight and I responded to him on
the 365th day Wow keeping track well
apparently I was going into my DMS and I
saw maybe 340 or something I'll wait
until 365 give him a little 1-year
anniversary surprise I opened to diem
once it said you ain't lovely and I said
I'm Dorothy I feel like that's a forever
comeback that you can have yeah any time
some of these anything rude you can just
say I'm Dora but wait no one can compete
with that the power that that holds is
just remarkable all right
what has Kiernan Shipka been in
I've been in madmen chili mentioned
Sabrina and let it snow November aids on
Netflix watch it for sure what does
Karen ship could do I know well I'm
currently sitting next to my friend
Isabella doing this doing this wire to
auto-complete interview what height is
Karen Shipka so I'm five three and a
half occasionally I feel like I'm more
of a five-four kind of gal other times I
feel like a shrink but let's just say
five three and a half to keep it neutral
yeah to keep it Switzerland what um what
color are Kiernan Shipka xyce hazel very
hazel yes I would say so
food plays like I'm here to confirm yep
can confirm hazel eyes what school did
Kiernan Shipka go to I didn't
independent study program growing up and
then I did some online college courses
and I'm still learning and still
figuring out what I'm gonna do there so
yep that's me boom
where is Isabela Merced parents from my
dad it was born in Cleveland Ohio
shoutout CLE the land then my mom is
actually from Peru Lima you should I
would gladly show you around I have the
big mountain in the little mountain and
they say you feel spiritual when you get
to the top but really I just think
you're so exhausted so hydrated just
like I feel all of the spirits what is
this a poem I said right now I am here
in the moment with you not really though
they'll be watching this yeah so right
now we can't really answer yes when
you're out when you're out there is no
nothing it's been a long day it's got a
long day where did Isabella Merced grow
up I grew up in Cleveland
nice yeah Cleveland Ohio it's a great
place thanks so much for watching guys I
hope you learned something new about us
but don't